most people of a think that faith in
some way should should shape the whole
of their lives not just their private
lives not just their interior lives but
their whole lives including their work
lives including their economic activity
but then immediately the question arises
well how should faith shape their
everyday activities work activities how
does faith connect with the life of a
person say within a larger corporation
and this is the topic of discussion for
today do we have something like or can
we have something like a faith-based
corporation or if we don't have a
faith-based corporation can the values
of faith be brought to bear on the life
of corporation or even maybe to a lesser
degree is it possible to have something
like faith friendly corporation a
corporation in which a person of faith
does not feel that he needs to or she
needs to hang his or her faith at the
entrance to their workplace and then
take it back on put it back on after the
work has been done how can faith be
integrated into a life of a person who
is serious about their work but at the
same time serious about their faith
their series of issues of this sort
that's world around the work faith and
the economic activity and we need to
explore these we need to explore for
instance what is the relationship of a
corporation to a broader culture that is
infused by faith what happens when
values of a corporation clash with
values of a particular culture in which
in this globalized world a corporation
is conducting this business this is a
significant issue significant issue for
the people of faith but significant
issue also for corporations for all the
economic agents in the world today